so you're looking at your Oscar ballot
and you get to the hair and makeup
category and you have to decide which
film to choose can be kind of difficult
to know exactly what's worth an Oscar
but we have some experts in the hair and
makeup field here with us today to give
us a little insight into their craft
question really is what makes hair and
makeup oscar-worthy one of the things
that I find to be most essential is how
well that body of work blends into the
storyline and doesn't pull you away from
the story of course some some makeup
creations are going to be a little more
elaborate a little more fantastical than
others so you sort of take it on a
case-by-case you know basis and it also
has to be true to the character if the
character is aging then there has to be
a very subtle transformation unless it
there's a definite time cut but it has
to show what that characters may be
going through has gone through and if
its innovative that's even better
sometimes the really obvious ones are
the ones that will get voted cuz people
can see the makeup thing and we're
trained to make our work so subtle and
natural like with the application of
wigs people don't even notice sometimes
that the actress is wearing a wig and
they think you just run in with a brush
then you sit down all day we have a lot
of work to do that's that's the real
subtle work is the hardest but the
voters never really understand because
they can't see it one of the tools that
we always use or a question that we
always use in the Academy is without
this makeup in this film do you still
have a film do you still have a story
does it still work without the makeup
and that is a true sign of a makeup that
helps move the story and helps the the
audience members sort of become a part
of that story emotionally as well as
visually so I think if you were to look
at the movies that are being nominated
and then say to yourself if this makeup
didn't exist would the story still work
there's great examples in the history of
filmmaking where it's just very obvious
or without the makeup the movie doesn't
work
oh look picture right there oh hey
wizard of oz I mean about the Tin Man
without the Scarecrow the movie doesn't
work you can't just have three guys
there are there a couple of suggestions
each of you would give to your average
movie fan about what to look for when
they're watching these movies and want
to pick out judge what's best in hair
and makeup it seems very sort of
elementary but watch all three movies
yes you know it's it's does a disservice
to everybody if you haven't watched all
three movies that are being nominated
and give yourself an educated vote
that's absolutely true that's right so
more people have a lot more publicity in
it can don't get caught up in the
publicity you really use your own
judgment but those three movies are all
deserving of an Oscar that's why they're
there not one is deserving they're all
deserving but one's gonna walk away with
the award the work to me usually stands
out if it's in harmony with everything
else with the faces and with the
lighting but at the same time is really
beautiful and brings something is like a
clever twist to to bringing some sort of
style to the movie without taking over
the story there's that it and they have
to be believable yeah hair and makeup
can either make your character very
believable where it propels you through
the story or it can be a distraction and
if it's a distraction that's a bad and
all these guys in mind that if you watch
the movie and you don't know what makeup
that you're voting for it's probably
that good cuz you don't know that
there's makeup it's probably an if it's
so if it's being nominated there's a
reason why is it a good rule of thumb if
you're not in this field to say if
you're asking yourself how did they do
that the bets and you're pressed by that
why did they do that
is that a good rule of thumb why is a
great question when someone says it's
like it's like being a magician and
watching a magic trick that melts your
your brain you know you you want to know
how that was done and yet you appreciate
what it took to get there you know so
yeah that's that's exactly the same
dynamic for us great well I want to
thank you all for being here walking us
through your process thank you and now
that you know a little more about makeup
and hairstyling you can use that
expertise and go to Oscar com fill out a
my pics game ballot and share your
predictions with friends